There are good reasons you see
so many people with Latin tattoos.
For a start, Latin is a highly
economical language -
you can say a lot
in just a handful of words.
Another reason
is that Latin literature
is full of timeless truisms.
Observations made
over 2,000 years ago
are often as applicable to us now
as they were to the Romans.
Here are five quotes
from Latin authors
I feel are just as relevant
to us today.
Number one:
Non videmus manticae
quod in tergo est.
We cannot see the baggage
that's on our own back.
In the mid-1st Century BC,
the Latin love poet, Catullus,
observed a common human trait.
While we find it easy to
recognise faults in other people,
we tend to be more or less
blind to our own.
"Each of us has been assigned
his own fault," he wrote,
"but we cannot see the baggage
that's on our own back."
Catullus' message then,
from over 2,000 years ago,
is to think about your own faults
before criticising others.
Two:
Omnia vincit amor.
Love conquers all.
Love, in Virgil's line,
isn't just a human emotion,
it's a divine force.
Love, amor, is Cupid,
the son of Venus,
the goddess of love.
He will strike you with his arrow
and make you fall hopelessly in love.
The love-sick poet who sighed,
"Omnia vincit amor"
knew that to be in love isn't
necessarily to be happy.
To be in love is also to be in pain.
Virgil shows us there's no point
in trying to fight it.
"Omnia vincit amor,
et nos cedamus amori" he continues.
"You're better off yielding to love
than trying to shield yourself
from his spell."
Three:
Si hortum in bibliotheca
habes deerit nihil.
If you have a garden and a library,
you'll lack nothing.
Cicero actually wrote,
"If you have a garden
in the library, you'll lack nothing."
Houses in Rome typically had the
garden in the middle of the house
rather than at the back.
In the ancient world there was
a tradition for learning outside.
Students at Plato's academy
in Greece, for instance,
used to learn among the trees.
Cicero's message is if you have books
and nature you have everything.
Four:
In vino veritas.
In wine is truth.
Anyone who has drunk
a few glasses can vouch for this.
Wine loosens the tongue.
It may make you talk a lot
of nonsense but as the ancients knew,
it could also make you
spill your secrets.
The historian Pliny the Elder
alluded to a popular saying,
about wine bringing out the truth.
"Veritas vino est."
At the same time, he pitied the
drunks who do not see the Sun rising
and therefore live shorter lives.
Five:
Donec eris sospes
multos numerabis amicos.
For as long as you're doing well,
you'll have many friends.
Ovid was one of the leading poets
of his day
but fell foul of the emperor
and was banished to the coast
of modern Romania.
While there he wrote
about his miserable fate,
which he blamed on a poem
and a mistake.
The poem was full of advice
about how to love and make love
and was far too
raunchy for his times.
What the mistake was remains
a mystery to this day.
In exile, the once popular poet
found himself friendless.
The message is surely to work out
who your real friends are
before it's too late.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notificatons for new videos.
See you again soon!